ladies and gentlemen the 45th and final
President of the United States
[Applause]
[Music]
first let me just take a moment to
insult Jeff Sessions Jeff you look like
a melting Gap Kids mannequin okay you
got it
moving on how do you respond to
criticism of your band of transgender
people in military service like this I'd
like to introduce you to my favorite new
team member who I will eventually betray
Anthony scaramouche
the president thank you I love the
president I love it I love my love my
love freakin love you thank you I'm
gonna fire so many people I don't know
who it's gonna be right but I'm gonna
get to the bottom of the leakage in the
White House you hear me rights there's
an old Italian expression my mother used
to use when somebody hurt her
she'd say stick the umbrella up my ass
but don't open it Wow and I love
president chump he's the love of my life
and I love love I love love
I can suck my own you supported
Democrats were pro-choice and program
control you're talking to Miriam because
we both did that this guy is phenomenal
I've seen him at Madison Square Garden
in a topcoat hitting foul shots swish
swish it's swish I've also seen him
either live raccoon bones and all I got
a Siamese house cat Wow who is this guy
sounds phenomenal it's you it's me yes
yes my love this is the new reality
which brings us to tonight's theme
telling the theme mooch joe paterno what
school's out to me the theme is reality
that's right
reality I started out on reality TV and
now I'm getting you to face the reality
that Russia is good Europe is bad and
America is a sewer full of cesspools
overflowing with carnage it's terrible
it's terrible I don't like it correction
I love it I love it too I could barely
tell where you end and I start